welcome to this video playing Pasha
Pasha I don't know yeah I go time on off
that I still don't know hmm yeah fo yeah
i recently had problems with that move
was it exactly he or i don't know but ok
let's go be five that shouldn't be such
a bad approach and just play the Queen
side hmm ok it's not so that's so clear
and what I want to take with but I get
some relatively quick pressure now we're
before is a I'm sorry is a threat hmm
isn't that good here for me that looks
like a nice position for black the only
concern is of course that my development
is not especially brilliant yeah
we should see 5 or not
we should see five speeds up the whole
thing maybe Jack dark squares look a bit
too they look a little bit suspicious
suspicious sounds like a been fine gold
but I really didn't think of him when
using this word anyway I have see foul
play and i also have Bishop to g5 as a
possible move to block any possible
pressure on the D file when a for I go
be4 mayor so it looks okay hmm
interesting maybe I have six getting a
complete change center shouldn't be bad
a full center
not really okay okay now i'm in for each
form it's not really reacting to any of
it h4 sg4 k maybe it is roop to d4 then
a choice is an interesting idea however
it will take f5 then okay it still makes
some sense maybe to put it on the form
again go King f6 then root tea for and
then aged form maybe you should just
play it for himself actually huh now
that I think of it that would make quite
some sense Eric g5 was stupid and yeah
you should go age for which she doesn't
do okay
we are stepping out of this efile step
hoping for luke t find H flow
Group D for what is he doing then C 3 ok
for Bishop see to something like that
yeah anyway I think see three years am a
useful move to provoke no it's not
reacting to anything and now I can go
age four I mean this was really a long
way in the making that move but never
really reacted to it yeah this looks
nice now check check their I mean I can
always check just to go back there no
even this is not working check here I'm
going away I can escape and look on the
seventh I go rook h2h seven there's
nothing happening really
not just to win actually he absolutely
didn't react to my age for idea
surprisingly attending f1 now picking up
that pawn how I actually played there
for immediately now I can go to see
three that wasn't necessary I mean it's
not exactly terrible but why did I allow
that in the first place don't know
really
so let's see how to do this probably
getting around yes right hook a 832 and
then the ponds are free to go what's
still very bad technical play by me
should have been over before that
some chick first check check I Scott
Luke will be three time warning let's do
this for us that's probably more precise
check it's still a win but again I
didn't play that well check check white
resigns yeah it should have been much
clearer technically made some
superficial moves down yeah this end
game is so I think probably equal I
shouldn't be there's no reason to claim
anything for either side and f6 yeah
cheeks it I mean I must say I rather be
black here because of that Center but
it's still equal of course this f5 I
think you can actually play age form and
just try to fix fix the whole thing now
maybe I really this is maybe I should do
this immediately I wasn't really sure
about this thing
but I'm actually far too quick that with
the pit the pawn yeah wins Amir limb
yeah then I should go h4 and again had
eight Roy has to play himself again and
now really and after this I'm
essentially witness at him 3d yeah just
like that picks up the pawn it from here
it should be a very easy technical task
but then make life a little bit
difficult by a favor cheeking I mean it
sorry easier to play a 4 immediately
check like this and then I know I
grabbed a tree I think this is a bit
simpler even though this is of course
nice EDF three-year I saw that but I
thought it's better to to use the bishop
here a bit more actively yeah maybe I
didn't really spoil it but the engine
always gives me a win so probably
probably I didn't play Adam check so
terribly but there were simpler simpler
solutions for for sure in general this
is a game that is pretty nice
illustration of that old author joke
that we heart all once made he said if
black equalizes in the sicilian then
he's better sounds a bit funny but there
is some truth it which means that in
black is not somehow getting killed
quickly quite often he will have the
better game because of his structural
advantages yeah the open sea file an
extra center porn in the open Cecilia
and well yeah I wasn't really better but
it was idea that there's no particular
thing that white can set its hopes on it
looks some fairly fairly okay
even though he can go if roya and
pointed out by the engine maybe this is
an interesting way to play maybe he has
something here that is very much
possible yeah that's true maybe you have
to improve with this and like this yep
and this is the way to play yeah it
should be equal really I don't claim an
advantage but it should be about equal
ok well thanks for watching